thanks
author alex kershaw talks about the
jacksons an american family who aided
the french resistance in nazi-occupied
paris
they lived on avenue fosh a street where
many gestapo and ss officers resided
during the occupation
this hour-long talk is part of a
multi-day conference at the national
world war ii museum in new orleans
i hope everyone had ample time to get
books stretch your legs and enjoy lunch
because up next is one of the museum's
most featured historians
alex kershaw
alex has been a guest speaker over the
years sharing his deeply personal
stories of individuals who made dramatic
differences during this global conflict
he has made his impact with book
launches and conference appearances here
in new orleans
but also by being one of our featured
historians on many of our european tours
including normandy and the battle of the
bulge
he is here to talk about his latest book
avenue of spies
which was the basis for a tour alex just
got back from last night
where we took people from normandy
following the bedford boys
then to paris with a remarkable story
we're about to hear
unfolded during the nazi occupation
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming alex kershaw
wow can you hear me okay
good um
can you hear me over here if i walk
around if i pace around nervously if i
walk the avenue of spies can you hear me
good um
well it's great to have you here
fantastic fantastic audience um
i'm going to be very politically
incorrect now and i'm going to say
something that i probably shouldn't say
but i'm actually going to thank someone
from the museum who
is the reason why i'm standing here
right now um
please jeremy collins can you stand up
and put your hand up wherever you are
sir where is jeremy
[Applause]
the reason why i'm going to embarrass
him briefly and uh please forgive me for
this
it's because
jeremy first invited me to go on a tour
with the museum
several years ago we spent three weeks
together
and he's been a big supporter of me over
the years and it was on a
a trip
to
europe that i came across the idea
of the book up here
avenue of
spies
this is um
a famous
color photograph from uh world war ii
it's a it's pretty rare
um on the left you'll see over here
the second nazi flag here
uh it's just outside the uh hotel
maurice
which was the headquarters for
von choletz uh during the german
occupation of
the city of light and it was while
jeremy and i were walking not staggering
i should say while we were walking
along here a few times late at night
that i decided that i had to try and
work out a
convincing plan to get a new york
publisher to give me enough money to go
and get
drunk several times
in paris
which unbelievably i managed to do
so um
so anyway without uh too much to do i'll
i'll get on with the story i'll try and
whip through
some fairly evocative images
first of all i wanted to read you i'm
not really a great believer in reading
anything from
any book that i've written because
people tend to fall asleep
i notice that there's no wine on the
tables which is a
a good thing because you definitely
would be falling asleep if you'd had
some other lunch
this is what a frenchman a
a very brave frenchman
and there were many during world war ii
including i should say de gaulle
um this is what he said about
belonging to the army of the knight
the secret army the frenchmen and women
who gave everything to defeat fascism
and nazism and terror for over 1500 days
and nights
we lived in the shadows as soldiers of
the night
but our lives were not dark
and martial
there were arrests
torture
and death
for so many of our friends
and comrades
and tragedy
awaited all of us
just around the corner
but we did not live
in or with tragedy
we were exhilarated
by the challenge
and the rightness of our cause
it was in many ways the worst of times
and in just as many ways
the best of times
and the best is what we remember today
so i've said this before i think that um
that quote
is uh powerful and it's evocative
because it reminds us of what i think
many of us here today feel about world
war ii and
the veterans here i'm sure there are a
few choose to remember about world war
ii we don't want to focus on
too often
that the terror and the darkness and the
death and the suffering we want to
remember
heroism the human spirit at its finest
sacrifice
and humanity at its very
brightest
um on the left over here uh sumner
jackson uh he's in uniform
um
it would be
um an understatement to say that he was
born poor um he was born in the
backwoods of maine walbro
his dad was a
part-time labourer he left school at 14
to go and work in a quarry
and
by 1917 i had managed to qualify as a
doctor
almost miraculously
i mean this is an example of american
meritocracy at its finest
and he volunteered to
serve with the british on the somme
in the first world war and this is him
on the left
in a uniform he's a doctor
obviously this is him on his way over
to france
in 1917
um
[Music]
he uh he met his wife um a swiss
french nurse called toquet
um in the
in an operating theater he's at the head
of the table furthest from me
um it's thought that toquet his future
wife is
right at his side right on the immediate
left and this is in the rue bikini it's
a hospital for wounded american soldiers
doughboys and um
other allied troops um
during the first world war in paris
um sumner
fell in love with toquet
their son philip told me that when they
met in the hospital in the rue bikini
they would um they would kiss each other
in a uh clothes a closet
um
very often but this is them taken in the
early 1920s so suddenly decided to stay
in france he fell in love with toquet he
gave up his career gave up his family
gave up everything in the us
to be at toquet's side had to retrain as
a doctor in france the french were
anti-semitic in many ways they didn't
want jews from eastern europe to come
and replace their doctors in france so
they made anybody that was from a
different country come to france and
re-qualify as a doctor so sumner jackson
spent another five years
when he could have been practicing
medicine in the u.s he spent five years
in the u in france re-qualifying as a
doctor but his son told me it was worth
it because he was madly in love with
toquet here they were very keen tennis
players she actually was one of the
finest tennis players of her generation
she beat the um a great french champion
many many times
this is philip with his father born in
the late 1920s he's alive today um
almost 90. this is taken outside the
front of number 11 avenue fosh uh that's
sumner and uh
and phillip there the railings you'll
see just behind them the blurred lines
are still there today
um i'm going to flick through some of
the the family photos this is their
their dog this is
something they're very powerful a chain
smoker but very fit very powerful uh man
um it's spent most of his youth um
performing heavy labor
and this is then uh the jackson's philip
the the dog the his mum and dad in the
late 1930s they went to normandy every
summer on holiday and actually those
people who know a little bit about d-day
when i say that this is juno beach
you'll know what i mean it's where the
canadians landed on
june the 6th 1944
here's philip um slightly older the
gentleman on the left a guy called renee
lagar
taught philip to swim in the cold choppy
waters of the english channel
philip would later owe his life to this
man because he's learned to swim in the
english channel while in the swimming
pool he was able to survive later on
here we have the avenue fosh named after
the famous french general
the french general marshall fosh
who had predicted the day that the
germans were forced to surrender at the
end of world war one that it would be um
an armistice for only 20 years in fact
marshall fosh was rung by only a couple
of weeks
the second world war broke out almost to
the day when marshall frosh predicted it
would um the most exclusive address in
paris on june the 14th
1940 the nazis uh
conquered paris conquer is the right
word
and the leading
vermact officers and certainly
the gestapo and the ss
chose the nicest places to live in paris
and the avenue fosh home of the ross
childs of
um the andre renault the car
manufacturer was the most attractive
address for the senior uh gestapo and
vermax figures and they commandeered
houses they basically chose any place
they wanted to live and they took it
over
this is number 11 avenue fosh
you'll see this is only taken a few
years ago i was there
literally only five weeks ago with a
group from the
world war ii museum on the res the
chaucer is the ground floor flat where
the jacksons lived um just behind the
black iron railings there
in july 1940 this gentleman here a
princeton graduate one of america's
earliest spies
was taken in by summer jackson he was
protected by summer jackson who was
working senator jackson worked at the
american hospital in paris
donald costa found his way to the
american hospital
he'd been working as a volunteer
ambulance man
in fact that was a front he was actually
one of uh
the um
america's earliest spies we didn't have
a foreign intelligence service before
the second world war um the oss was
formed after 1940 but you did have
people that worked for the american
state department all over the world and
they were your earliest spies and donald
costa
was one of those men he later was
involved
in the planning of operation torch in
1942 when the oss really kicked in and
went into action
in an interview in 1981 he said that
summer jackson hit him in the basement
of the american hospital
in the summer of 1940 until he could
find the appropriate papers and a way
out of nazi conquered france
so this is the first
first connection that the
jackson family have with intelligence
and the first risk that someone jackson
took during world war ii to aid
intelligence efforts
um by the fall of 1940 here um i have a
flag in my
in front of me um you'll see that i've
highlighted some of the um the buildings
where the gestapo were most active
um number 11 is shown there
um if you go along the avenue and you
have good good eyesight i don't but
you'll see
um that
several of the buildings have been taken
over by the senior gestapo um people
like helmut knockin
uh hans kiefer other
um very powerful figures within the uh
the ss
apparatus in occupied paris
um
actually this here is an arrow pointing
to number 72 that's helmut knockin he uh
eventually became the head of the
gestapo in paris
and therefore by 1943 44 the most
powerful man in all of occupied france
this is him here he was 36 years old
when he arrived in paris on the 14th of
june 1940
has a phd in medieval english literature
an academic that became a very very
devoted nazi
he
arrived in paris in disguise on june
14th 1940 disguised as a military
policeman not as an ss officer
because the vermax the senior vermax
generals in paris
on in june of 1914 didn't want
any of these so-called gentlemen
anywhere near paris
they were called the black bastards by
the senior vermont officers
if you were a prussian aristocrat you
didn't want this kind of person in the
most beautiful city on the planet that
you now dominated
these people
when they arrived you had extermination
followed
you had assassination you had all of the
apparatus of the gestapo and the ss that
arrived too
so the vermont didn't want these guys
around and that's why they arrived in
disguise
and that's why from
early
june 1940 right and through right until
almost 1943 the ss and the gestapo
struggled to dominate the situation in
paris and also france
moving on
if i can get this to work
um this is the winter of 1940 in
angkyong just outside paris on the left
is sumner jackson he's still working at
the american hospital in paris
he was allowed to stay many americans
were interned by the germans but because
of some of jackson's connections he was
allowed to stay on as the
chief surgeon at the american hospital
in paris this to the right is philip
jackson um
philip told me that he loves his
photograph because it shows him and his
father
together they weren't together very
often because something was so busy
it also shows some that it is possibly
his happiest
he loved to use his hands he loved to
carve he loved to be outdoors
and he came from the backwoods of maine
and this
this is a reminder if you like of the
lifestyle and the
the upbringing that he's left behind in
the us
um may of 1942 this is taken at all the
airport um those of you who know your
your history of the third reich and in
particular the ss will recognize the
central figure that's uh
heydrich
um i would
i would say that he was responsible uh
could be described easily as the
architect of the final solution
um he was the uh
he was there at the bonsai conference
when they planned the the final genocide
a final solution rather
he's he he's arrived in paris
to
make sure that the ss and in particular
the gestapo are
placed in the position of primary power
but the vermont is fully undermined and
that france becomes an ss state
with the ss rather than the vermont of
the ones that call the shots
uh to his immediate right is helmut
knockin
um he's a a protege of heydrich heydrich
in fact was his more than a mentor he
was a protector and inspiration
and to the far left over here we have
carl oberg ss general karl oberg
who's also arriving for the first time
in paris oberg will be placed above
knocking knocking will become the head
of the gestapo in paris oberg will run
the ss in france and france will become
an ss state
a racially pure place where the ss and
the gestapo and hitler's most fanatical
followers will make sure that what they
want to get done is done
and they will murder and assassinate and
do anything they need to to destroy
their main opposition which is the
french resistance
so the man on the left here helmet on
the left here oberg and the man on the
right over here
knocking
the french today would argue and they
are right i believe that the two of them
are responsible for the murder the mass
murder over over 160 000
french civilians
eighty thousand french civilians who
were jewish and eighty thousand
around about eighty thousand resistance
french civilians who dared to defy them
um in july 1943 um a a guy called joe
manos a b-17 uh
waste gunner was shot down over paris um
i interviewed him four years ago
um and this is an escape and evasion
report that he made when he got back to
england
over 3 000 americans
completed what were called home runs one
of the most incredible feats that any
american
managed in world war two and the home
run meant that if you were shot down
over northern europe
in germany's case it was rheem
you managed through connections with the
french resistance to get to the pyrenees
climb the pyrenees get to spain and then
be ferried back to england
in fact joe manas went back to the very
same pub
where he'd drunk before his crew had
left for their mission before he was
shot down
for two weeks he was interrogated very
severely and he resented it for the rest
of his life
he had been through hell he'd been
helped by over 50 people within the
french resistance
he told me when he got back to england
they spent two weeks they quarantined
him and they interviewed him at great
great length because they thought that
he could be a double agent that he may
have been turned by the gestapo and then
came back to become a spy
he wasn't the spy but in this report
that he made very very detailed report
he mentions a doctor sumner jackson
he made his way through an escape line
which was connected to the liberation
resistance movement to the american
hospital
where he met in summer jackson's office
with some of the jackson and then in
this report he says that summoner
jackson took him back to his home at 11
avenue fosh
in july of 1943.
it's thought that sumner jackson
helped several
other downed allied flyers to escape to
spain
this is the only actual visual evidence
the only documented evidence that i
could find of joe manos of one of them
but it's thought that he helped not just
germanoff but he was part of an escape
line that helped many others
get to spain
um
by the uh late summer of 1943 um the war
against the ss and gestapo's war against
the resistance has really hotted up
um
they know that the major aid from france
itself
for any allied invasion will come from
the french resistance
um the ss and gestapo also know that the
an invasion is going to come at some
point
maybe even in the fall of 1943 that was
believed by some
certainly in some point in 1944 the
allies would invade france
and they gestapo and the ss were
determined to prevent the french
resistance from helping them
so they went to war with the resistance
and uh
they destroyed any
and anybody that was involved with the
resistance
and used all kinds of techniques to do
so
um here you have number 84 we mentioned
helmut knockout number 72
by the late summer 1943
his empire has grown from number 72 to
number 74 and also number 76 but at
number 84 here you have hans kiefer
also
a senior ss officer and he becomes one
of the most successful spy hunters of
the third reich and he specializes in
capturing soe agents special operations
executive british agents many of them
woefully trained one of the untold
stories well it's not untold but
one of the myths of world war ii is that
the british made decent spies in france
we were disastrous
it was a
it was a child's game as the ss
described it themselves it was a child's
game to capture british spies in france
you had posh englishmen arriving with
brogues and bad french accents
that would be literally arrested within
hours of walking into a cafe
they were amateurs many of them
which is not to undermine
the broader intelligence efforts of the
british during world war ii but to pick
on france when you point to france you
have to say that it was a disaster
it was an absolute disaster and the guy
that was the um
the chief
bloodhound for the nazis the guy that
tracked down most of our best soe agents
was a former policeman from karlsruhe in
germany hans kiefer very good colleague
of helmut knockin and there was a number
84 that some of our finest agents were
tortured before they were sent to
concentration camps in nazi germany viet
zabo for example was
tortured
severely
if you've seen the film carve her name
with pride she was a really very
beautiful and very
very charming aggressive cocky young
british working class
woman that had married a frenchman and
was
parachuted into france and she was
interrogated at length at number 84
avenue fosh which was by
the summer of 1943 was called avenue
bosch because there were so many germans
that lived there
so moving on now if i can get this thing
to
um
francis
de los de noil
he
lived just next door to the jacksons on
the roof tracked here it's a photograph
taken of him just
three years ago he's still alive he's 96
years old today
incredibly he's part of the team the
french team that first climbed annapurna
in 1950 and annapurna we we the british
managed to summit everest or i'm sorry i
didn't mean that i should take that back
but before everest was conquered the
highest mountain that had been climbed
was annapurna and this guy was part of
the french team that climbed it he was
also part of the french resistance in
august 1943 he knocked on the front door
at number 11 and met with tockett
jackson and told her i belong to the
french resistance
i have something to ask you
would you be prepared to use your house
as a meeting place and a drop box for my
resistance group go let forget
and he told me that tuckett
who by this time was
54 years old
didn't hesitate for a second she said
yes
you can use our home as a meeting place
for resistance agents
um
the decision to join the resistance was
a very serious one obviously
she had a husband sumner jackson and she
had a 15 year old son philip jackson so
by deciding to
use 11 avenue fosh as a
a place where the resistance could meet
and where intelligence was dropped she
was risking not only her life but her
husband and her son's life but she was
still prepared to do so
august 1944 this is a photograph taken
at number 72
avenue fosh the headquarters for helmut
knock and it's taken by cartier-bresson
the great french photographer one of the
founder members of magnum he was in
paris on the 25th of august 1944 when it
was liberated by
french
second armored division and also
americans let's not forget that the
fourth infant division fought right to
the heart of paris on the 25th of august
1944
and uh on the avenue fosh uh where
second armoured tanks rolled
um cartier-bresson went into one of the
offices of the gestapo this one here and
he took what i think is quite an
atmospheric shot of the polished boots
of a senior ss official
and it shows the papers being discarded
the haste with which the gestapo left
paris
after 1500 days and nights of occupation
um
in late may of 1944 literally just a
couple of weeks before d-day
there was a knock on the front door the
knock on the front door finally came at
11 avenue fosh
and the police the
fascist paramilitary force
under the vichy regime the police
arrived
and they arrested toket sumner jackson
and philip jackson
torquette found herself in ravensbrook
the largest prison for women in history
uh it's thought that over 50 000 women
perished in ravensbrook during the
second world war this is the winter of
1944-45 um this is an unusual photograph
because it shows the women
at that period in the camp's history
actually wearing uniforms
taket was a part of a group of french
resistance
fighters
who only wore summer dresses
for the winter of 1944-45
she was the oldest by 10 years among the
group that were deported from paris with
her
and she was the only one to survive
of a small group that deported on the
15th of august 1944 from paris
here she is on the 29th of april 1945.
she's um she's in malmo
and she's been rescued by the
swedish
red cross
at the 11th hour
um
i'm going to read you quickly this is
the 29th of april 1945. she's just got
off a boat that's come across the baltic
and she's with a group of other women
who have been saved from ravensbrook
she writes to her sister
in paris
my sister
i know nothing about you since we saw
each other at romaine veal which is in
paris
do you have any news of jack
the nickname she had for her husband
sumner
or pete
the name she used for philip her son
if my handwriting seems to tremble
it is because i have open wounds
on three fingers
and no eyeglasses
i also have ototitis
and my ears run
i can't hear on one side
my feet are swollen
and i have terrible dysentery
he's 57 years old
but after all that
my morale is good
it is a miracle
i am not dead
and to think that i will see you soon
no time for more
kisses your sister
so turket jackson survived but she
didn't know if her husband and her son
who were deported to the third reich
around the same time if they had
survived
um this is philip in the summer of 1945
he did survive but he didn't know that
his mum his mother had lived
um i'm going to read you one more
one more short section from here
um
philip
found himself
on may the 4th 1945
on the theobeck
a prison ship in the baltic
there were three prison ships
near lubeck and they came contained over
12 000
concentration camp survivors
um around 10 000
men had been taken from noyengamma a
work camp
philip had been among them with his
father and on the 4th of may the raf
decided that they were going to sink any
ship that was afloat in the baltic and
that's exactly what we did
and we killed over 12 000 people on the
4th of may
1945
three days from the end of the war
sank every ship that floated in the
baltic
including the theobek where philip
and his father were held
beneath the decks philip managed to
somehow miraculously survive he was one
of 200 people from over 2000 on the
fieldback who lived but his father was
drowned he uh
he was uh liberated by the british and
for the summer of 1945 he worked with
the british as an interpreter because he
spoke fluent german and obviously
english and french
and this is a photograph taken of him in
the summer of 1945.
finally he discovered that his mother
had survived and she wrote to him and
said where are you please come back to
paris
he told me that it was september
1945 when he got on the metro in paris
um
he crossed paris and he got out at
litwal
which is near the arctic triomphe
and he walked along the avenue fashion
he walked back to his house
his mother was there to greet him at the
front door at number 11. and he said i
went back into my bedroom which i'd left
a year and a half before and everything
was the same
my mother hadn't moved anything
he was 17 years old he'd been deported
when he was 16. and
he told me that for me
everything had changed i spent a year in
a concentration camp
my father had been killed i had missed
he told me i had missed my entire
adolescence i went from being a child a
boy to being a man
this is him in 1946
in hamburg
he testified in a war crimes trial
against the senior ss who had run
noyengamma
and
actually was in court when he was able
to point to nine
ss officers
and all of the nine
were executed by the british after the
war and he told me when i interviewed
him that that's the
single thing that he's proudest of
not belonging to the resistance but the
fact that he was able to testify against
men who had murdered
thousands
and that his testimony had been
important and had been believed and it
had led to the direct execution of nine
of what he described as monsters
uh people that he'd seen every day be
monsters people that had
made him lose all faith
in humanity
as a 16 year old
here's the um
the two men i showed you earlier on at
all e when they arrived that fateful
um
humid day in may of
1942 when they were the kings of france
when their twisted
poisonous
racist ideology held sway
throughout europe
before they had fully dispatched
over 160 000 frenchmen and women to
their deaths at the heart of the third
reich
oberg over here on trial in paris in
1954
and knockin
both were sentenced to death
by the french
the british also we insisted on trying
them we also censored them to death for
war crimes
for political reasons they were both
able to survive
and this gentleman here on the right
helmut knocking if you go and google his
name you'll see an american academic in
2003 sitting having lunch with him in
germany
where knocking became a very successful
insurance agent after the war
and knock and sits there this silver
main
pulled back
in 2003 he died at age 93 and he says
you know
i was never a criminal
i was never a genocidist i was never a
mass murderer i was serving my country
and the great tragedy of my life
what's so unfair about my life
is that yes i did organize the
deportations
yes i did sign the orders to send these
people to the third reich
but i didn't know
what was going to happen to them when
they got off the trains
at the end of their journeys
no one ever told me
a skilled
fantastic fabulous to the end
so
this is philip in 2014 and um
uh
it's a it's a great photograph uh taken
by a friend of mine because it shows you
the uh golden dome of laser angvalid
just behind him
and below that dome
as many american gis
from world war ii uh knew
because it was the most visited place by
american soldiers in in paris in world
war ii is the tomb of napoleon
and philip today
um lives a stone's throw
from napoleon's tomb in lies on the lead
he's one of a select few a very very
elite few
of the resistance who are allowed to
live in lesotho which is has huge
emotional and historic significance for
the french for anybody that's been
involved in the french military
that's the the place where the creme de
la creme
are looked after and nursed at the end
of their lives
and i have to say that um
five weeks ago it was my great
great honor and privilege to be able to
take 25 people
from a museum tour we did a trip to
france
and at the last minute i was able to
surprise all of them
and we were able to walk into the main
reception area of la zomba lead and we
were able to shake this man's hand
it's a very powerful experience for all
of us because we knew that all of us
were probably doing that for the very
last time
he maybe has
a year very most he's at the end of his
life
he hasn't got long to live and he didn't
look well
but it was a very
very very powerful
thing to be able to do
um
uh this is uh my ugly mug beside philip
jackson again 2014. um i'll move forward
because i can't stand looking at myself
at the best of time
anyway um
that was taken in a restaurant called
pasco which is a place that's phillip's
favorite restaurant very close to
leisunbleed um without being too much of
a booster i'm shameless i know but
that's where
the group from the museum where we had
dinner after we'd met philip that
afternoon it's his favorite restaurant
um
so
thank you for being such a a wonderful
audience um i wanted to
to read you just one last thing um
before
i disappear before you
um
before you spend the rest of your time
here listening to
wonderful historians
um it's a poem
by
violet zabo and indulge me please
because i'm something of a
sentimentalist if you hadn't already
realized
violet zabo was taken out one morning
she actually was in the same train wagon
as toquet jackson when she was deported
from france
in on august 15
the women were naked most of them
and it was a very hot day
very very hot and the metal roos of the
boxcars made it feel like a sauna inside
and the women's bodies slithered
together because they were perspiring so
much
and as some of the women collapsed they
would slide down each other's backs
and some of the women were seen on their
knees
and they were licking drops of sweat
that dropped from other women's backs
villetzaber was one of those women and
taket jackson was one of those women
she was taken out in
february of 1945 one morning with two
other british women soe agents
spies
and she was made to kneel down and she
was shot in the back of the head
and murdered
as many
of our finest intelligence agents were
who ended up on avenue fosh
but before she
arrived in france before she gave her
life to defeat nazism
um
she became an agent for the british
and leo marx who ran her who was her
boss
in the soe knew that she needed to
practice her code making
and leo marx wrote a beautiful poem
that vilet zabo would decode and code
and decode and code to practice her code
making
the life that i have
is all
that i have
and the life that i have
is yours
the love that i have
of the life that i have
is yours and yours
and yours
a sleep i shall have a rest i shall have
yet death will be but a pause
for the peace of my ears
in the long green grass
will be yours
and yours
and yours
thank you very much you've been a great
audience
if you have questions please raise your
hand so alex can get to them
we'll start in the center at the very
front
sorry i wanted to run away but uh
i'm not yet i'm not yet being deported
i've
just finished your book a couple of
months ago i think it's the fifth or
sixth of of yours by fred so get a plug
or rail today i'll take it thank you
just a question um what led to the
arrest of the jacksons um was it the one
incident or was it just a series of uh
observations by the gestapo
um
they belong to a a group called galette
fregat
and in fact um i managed to come across
the the document which um is in the
the archives
in paris which names
the members of that resistance
organization who were deported with the
jacksons
um in
on may the 22nd 1944
a safe house near vici was raided by
the gestapo and the middle east they
worked closely together
and they found a list of names
whoever had been operating that safe
house was very amateurish
the names weren't coded
and at the same time that they found the
list of names which included the
jacksons they also found some letters
addressed to a mrs jackson in paris
that's how they were
that's how they were given away so there
was nothing that happened in paris as
what happened in a different part of
france
with a different part of the same
organization
so in a way the simple answer was
complete amateurism you don't leave
lists of agents uncoded around and you
you certainly don't have letters
addressed to people
uh with their real names so
it was amateurism um okay to your left
alex
sorry
um
with the exception you talked about the
soe being
penetrated with the exceptions of the
jedburgs
what was the uh i don't know if you can
elaborate on this but there was a
certain department within soe that had
been terribly penetrated
in their communications
on the ground i thought it was a
department h or department
c could you
expound that a little bit um well
the uh the network that's most famous
for being penetrated which kiefer
rolled up pretty quickly um is prosper
um and that's the one that was um i mean
you get
several very famous agents in your khan
others that were involved in that
prosper network and that was particular
to france
so that was penetrated i believe in
early july of 1943
and the gestapo hans kiefer
was the guy that uh rolled that network
up and he did it very very very cleverly
and carefully um
when you arrived at 84 avenue fosh if
you were one of those agents from
prosper you arrived in a a van
i take people to the actual entry to the
the to number 84
nothing's changed you went underground
into a courtyard and then you were taken
up onto the second floor
of 84 avenue fosh and if you were
british
and most of the guys were posh
and most of the women were actually
very interesting because they had
married frenchmen or they'd spent part
of their lives in europe because they
were and they were picked as women
because they had experience of france
and they could they were bilingual
but you were taken to the second floor
and kiefer would have an englishman who
had already turned from prosper
he would be there with biscuits and tea
in sandwiches i don't know if the
sandwiches were cucumber sandwiches and
had the crusts cut off
but it was sophisticated and you'd be
offered a cigarette and the point was
sit down
cooperate have a nice cup of tea there's
no point resisting and if you don't
we'll talk to you and murder you later
on when we used you as we see fit
um
so um
prosper is the is the famous one in the
back of my book i have quite a long
story about a quite a lot of notes about
a couple of the agents from that
and it's seen as the classic example of
um
of uh how the gestapo in paris
so easily
undermined and and captured
british intelligence agents in soe
they have to remember that soe is not
mi6
i should say that if you google
if you're ever very very very bored
indeed
if you google my name
you'll see that i'm listed as an mi6
agent
from
my place of recruitment was geneva in
1997
and it says alex kershaw mi6
um
and it's because i went to a couple i
went to college with a few people that
did actually work for british
intelligence and probably still do work
for british intelligence but anyway i'm
not an mi6
operative
but the point is that mi6
existed all the time at the same time as
the soe
and mi6 thought that the soe was a bunch
of churchillian amateurs and they kind
of were soe was devised and inspired by
churchill he wanted
a group of
operatives to set europe aflame he said
um they were not professional
intelligence operatives in the sense
that mi6 were
and all the way through the war mi6
watched soe and some people believe that
mi6 set some of them up they were very
useful decoys so while mi6 got on with
the real business
of secret intelligence
churchill's
cowboys and cowgirls
paid the price
some people believed that
prosper in particular was betrayed by
mi6 operatives so the germans would
would swallow
a full story about when we were going to
invade france on d-day
prosper
propagated the idea that it would be the
fall of 1943 not the june of 1944 and we
wanted the germans to buy that so
mi6 used soe to do that so
prosper is the is the example of um how
easy it was for
uh
knocking
knocking in fact
uh interrogated some of the soe
uh members of of the prosper network um
in france
alex to your right
[Applause]
a comment first and then a question
i noticed that april 29th of 1945
was also the same day that felix sparks
liberated dachau so and interesting how
that plays out for uh protagonists and
another story
could you comment on the overall
effectiveness of the resistance movement
in in france and and and also i get a
sense from what i read that the french
look back on the second world war here's
a country with the largest army in the
world at one point gets rolled over by
the germans and nothing flat
and
and now the only
a matter of shame i think in in many
respects that somehow the resistance
movement seemed to kind of bolster
uh the french and how they look back
upon that period wow it's a you know if
the french ambassador is here please
leave the building now
um
maybe not given what just happened
recently but anyway um
uh that's a good question fantastic
question i don't want to go on too long
but i think you've raised a lot of very
you know very important points there
very it's a
a wonderful question um i'll be trying
to be brief um
and i'll do it i um
i went to see philip
the third time i went to see philip i
was rolling his in his wheelchair so
that we can go and get quite drunk at
his favorite restaurant which i already
showed you
and he was in his wheelchair and we were
on the third floor at liz on the lead
and um
a woman was in a wheelchair right beside
us that got into a lift
and she was slumped in the
wheelchair and she must have been in her
mid-90s
and she was drooling
and i looked at her and i looked at
philip and we went to lunch and the
french know how to treat their veterans
especially their resistance veterans
which is that they're which are a huge
deal for them
and we each sat nine of us all of them
very everybody in their late 80s early
90s
nine members of the french resistance
were in a separate room at lausanne
valid each table had a white linen
tablecloth and we had a half
a bottle of burgundy red wine for lunch
this is how they treat
their veterans and phillip said i sister
phillip who was that in the lift and the
he said oh she was in the resistance and
uh but you know
i haven't been able to sleep the last
week none of us on our ward
have had a wink of sleep because she's
been screaming every
night so
well over 70 years after the second
world war this woman wakes up in the
middle of the night screaming
because when she was caught by helmut
knockin's men when she was caught by the
gestapo
they were clever they were clever a lot
of the time and instead of killing her
and torturing her they made her parents
kneel down in front of her and they shot
her parents in the back of the head
and they said to her you can go free but
just remember to tell everybody else
that that's what's going to happen to
them too
so when you go to france and you go to
normandy i was there five weeks ago
when you talk to the french about de
gaulle about what happened in the second
world war
you'll have different reactions
some frenchmen i've talked to are very
very angry about the
accusation that somehow they lacked
spine that they gave up too easily that
they were so quickly defeated
hitler said in may of 1940 i will be in
paris in six weeks with my artists
and everybody thought he was crazy but
he was right
six weeks almost to the day
he was
wandering around
the highlights of paris
it was a terrible
moral emotional physical
shock to be defeated that quickly as a
proud as you were saying nation but
let's not forget that us brits we were
also defeated
we had dunkirk
the miracle so-called miracle of dunkirk
and if we hadn't had 21 miles of the
english channel they'd have been in
scotland
maybe they wouldn't have defeated the
scots quite as quickly as the brits
that's a nod to stephen watson by the
way but anyway um
hadrian's wall might have been built
quite quickly
some kind of wall anyway
sorry
but the english channel saved us
no one was immune blitzkrieg was
fantastic it worked it was the most
violent most modern
most effective form of warfare anybody
had seen
so yes the french were defeated
now in 1941
when sumner jackson became involved
helping downed allied airmen when he
became a resistant if you like although
he didn't join the resistance
he was almost alone in 1941 less than
five percent of the french population
had any kind of
connection to any opposition to german
rule
let alone accidentally becoming part of
the resistance and even in 1944
on the eve of d-day it was a very small
percentage of the french people were in
the resistance now after the war
the mythology the popular stories are
that you know everybody my dad my uncle
my you know everybody i knew that was
you know was in this resistance
it's not true
absolutely not true
um
the
very large grey area that most people
occupied during occupation
they didn't want to actively support the
nazis although there was mass
collaboration especially when things
were going the germans way in the first
few years of the war but even right on
the eve of liberation when americans and
british
were about to die in their tens of
thousands to liberate france there were
still very few
french men and women involved in the
resistance
when they were they were violent and
effective to a certain extent but they
had no weapons and the reason why they
had no weapons is we made damn sure they
didn't have any weapons
we made sure that the communists in
france who were in the resistance and
they are the most lethal and the most
effective
the communists were the ones that would
walk up behind you if you were german on
the metro and take a single a pistol
and shoot you
you're a communist if you did that you
were ideologically motivated stalin had
asked you to do it
but we didn't want those guys running
france
and in fact when i went to paris
recently i ended after this people
couldn't believe it when i said some
people couldn't believe it when i said
you know
can you imagine
um
normandy 50 000
americans
american casualties
9 386 it's no longer now 99 387. 9 386
americans buried in the graveyard above
omaha beach
imagine that sacrifice for nothing
imagine breaking out of normandy and
then discovering that the french
resistance have taken over paris and
their communists
and the french resistance have taken
over leon
limoges
and bordeaux and nice
their friend and their communists
what was the point
what would be the point of liberation
there would have been no liberation
so um i hope i've tried to answer your
your question i think that resistance to
to
finally to someone i think if we'd armed
them
it would have been a stupid thing to do
because we would have we would not have
been able to have a democracy in france
after the war
the communists heavily armed would have
would have run the country
the reason why we put de gaulle in
paris on the 26th of august 1944
even though we hated him everyone hated
him
um was because he was a figurehead we
needed a fighter we needed someone that
french would believe and support and and
um and follow
we didn't want a communist
that's why we ended up with de gaulle
we've got uh time for a quick question
to your right again alex
the the prevailing view i think is that
uh torture is not only barbaric but
ineffective
is that also true of the gestapo
experience with torture
um
well i don't know i mean whose
prevailing view is it is it that it's
not effective
i think it's pretty effective it would
work on me
i'd be having the cup of tea and saying
where's the next sandwich you know
well
i don't think it worked on
the right kind of agent if you had the
right kind of mentality and if you were
vetted properly and if you
were the kind of you had the kind of
steel that people wanted if you were
violet zabo for example
if you were to jackson
if you had that inner steel and that
spirit
then it didn't work no you're right it
didn't work on people that were
you know superhuman in a way that
couldn't be broken but on many people it
did um that's you know we can't have i
don't think you can have that kind of
binary of you successful or not
successful
i'd say in general that it doesn't work
it's not i don't think it's a
humane policy um
but
hiroshima wasn't particularly humane
either you know
when we talk about war
we have to talk about certainly in the
second world war we have to talk about
how we won it because it was important
to win it
um
so in any method
at the end
1945 certainly when we look at the world
war ii we have to be honest we have to
say it was mass industrial slaughter
and so torture becomes a rather arcane
moral argument
when you
in one night in tokyo 121 000 people die
from their homes being burned
as around them
we have to put it in that context so yes
i think that torture is wrong we should
never use it
but then
mass industrial slaughter surely is
also something that we should question
but what isn't questionable
is that
it's it had to be done we had to
we had to do anything we could
anything we could do to end that war and
to be victorious
um
the consequences of not doing that i
still i think everybody in this room
would agree
are too horrific to even begin to
start to process or
or imagine
i think um i want to take the
opportunity before we thank alex uh we
have a special guest with us a world war
ii veteran who himself had his own
french american relation during world
war ii uh to my right is judge khalis
salum who is from lafayette louisiana
and even though the language was
outlawed
the church and the culture allowed for
the french language to be strong down in
acadiana
thanks to that he was quickly put into
the counter intelligence corps during
world war ii in north africa he worked
with the french military but also the
civilian colonial colonialists down
there and then he participated in the
invasion of southern france so i just
wanted to recognize a special
veteran special hero thank you
[Applause]
and
thank you alex
[Applause]
you're watching american history tv all
weekend every weekend